Congressman Michael Waltz Republican out
of Florida service come to this wow
um what is good and what we just heard
there about what we can anticipate here
in the coming weeks
nothing Bill uh I this is this is an
absolute crisis and the bide
Administration it just continues to
shrug its shoulders and I I think so
many Americans are just asking why uh
you know they're a basic solution right
now is to increase shelter increase
services
and to Institute a pilot program where
they start interviewing people right
there on the border about whether their
Asylum claim is legitimate but when
you're doing that all you're doing is
green lighting to the world come on over
that we have more shelter we have more
assets to process you and then if we
don't we'll just send you right into the
interior and Bill I think what's so
frustrating is this is imminently
solvable
four basic steps number one build the
wall build barriers and put technology
On the Border number two put the remain
in Mexico policy back in place so people
have to wait there rather than they get
to get released into the border for
their Asylum claim three we talk a lot
about decoupling from China and bringing
manufacturing back home of course I'd
like it in the United States but if it
doesn't make sense here let's
incentivize it to go into Central
America create jobs there and secure our
supply chains now you're killing two
problems with one stone and then four we
have to go after the cartels and we've
talked about authorizing military
resources putting them on their back
foot but right now estimates show
they're making 10 to 15 billion dollars
per year off of human trafficking in
fentanyl uh I mean those four steps
right there bill and I think we would
have this problem largely under control
and that's what our Republican
legislation this week seeks to do the
White House seems to think it does not
have a problem listen to this exchange
at the White House briefing yesterday
you have laid out all the things that
wants to tackle
from the country careening toward a debt
limit crisis to you know the southern
border why is the president talking
about meal vouchers or canceled flights
and holding a movie night at the White
House
with all those things going on because
he's president and there are multiple
things that the president does and he
can talk about
the potential manufacturing crisis that
House Republicans have put forth
have you been a part of a plan to
manufacture a crisis
no we're actually trying to solve this
crisis Dana and and what's so
frustrating is look the left is shown
its hand this White House is beholden to
its base we saw it in the in the
Democrat primary where every single
candidate raised their hand during the
debate basically for open borders and
for free services and what has me so
frustrated as a representative is when I
talk to my constituents when I talk to
Veterans who don't have the services
that they need and deserve when I talk
to teachers whose classrooms are
overwhelmed our infrastructure that's
crumbling and yet those are you know
services rightly for American citizens
we talked about the debt limit debate
we're talking about whether this country
can sustain spending for American
citizens yet on the other hand the White
House shoulder shrugs at the prospects
of 8 million new people coming in and
putting a strain on those same services
like it's no big deal and that is unfair
to the taxpayer that's unfair to these
people who have paid into the system and
already aren't getting the services that
they deserve Michael thank you for your
time Congressman Michael Waltz buckle up
okay we'll be watching that every hour
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis